America third nanny non-fatal we want to
build a much better believable people
and we must do it not fatal
communication very much higher America
first to lead it by an any insiders
fighting for insiders time to stop
insiders fighting for insiders more of
insiders fighting for insiders time to
stop insiders fighting for insiders
America first love the flow 69
now it's time for new believable people
and we must do it if we don't control
insiders this will be over and over to
lead it by an anticline common ground to
halt the spread of lives and we must do
it big fabulous love by common ground to
halt the spread of lies fatal we want to
build a much better believable people
and we must do it not fatal
communication very much higher America
first to lead it by an any insiders
fighting for insiders time to stop
insiders fighting for insiders more of
insiders fighting for insiders
to stop insiders fighting for insiders
America
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after all
enough enough
[Music]
[Music]
hey shows coming up in a minute but you
know that especially if you're a member
of Mudd Club a lot of credit
accomplished mukla that's the only way
that any of this content is available
and I want to let you know that we had
to pre tape some things today some
elements because my wife is in the
emergency room probably fine
not kovat related actually could be
serious but so prayers are appreciated
I've seen some of the comments on
Twitter we will be talking about Donald
Trump's executive order in the last
segment and next Monday good morning
Mudd Club is going to be my half-asian
lawyer ins and outs of this executive
order that's all we're gonna do for you
enjoy the show
[Music]
welcome back to cultural appropriation
month
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter I just don't
understand why you hope tell me what
would make you as weak as any other
man's what what I repeat what is that it
why why would I tell you that oh you
don't trust me and that it is that a
serious question
you've got a serious question of course
I don't trust you the last time we went
out for drink Tuesday and happy hour you
said what would make you remember what
would make you as weak as any other man
we had a couple of daiquiris in it oh
you know what if I wake up tied in fresh
ropes lo and behold the very next
morning oh it was a sex thing was it was
it was it a sex thing because I don't
have any sex as part of that thing Obama
on the subject why don't you trust me
and I tell you you know if someone were
to tie my hair in a weave I would lose
all my power and I wake up like this
lobster I just need you to trust me oh
you need me to trust you okay now what
before we talk about your needs forget
about my needs at all the strongest man
in the world who's who's actually tasked
with ensuring the bloodline of the
Lord's people effect with Jimmy Jimmy
how hard it is to kill over a dozen
people with the jawbone of a donkey No
do you know how hard it is to actually
get a jawbone of a donkey even gonna
work if you don't trust me okay boxed
boundaries no thanks I need to work on
this together we're a team
we are not each other's enemy my hair
okay that's the source of all my power
you want me to trust you
there it is I'm being vulnerable instead
of angry because anger is not an emotion
it simply masks the real emotion we know
that my hair were cut I'd be as weak as
any other
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey glad to be with you you know what
that is that's that's because I'm
inspired by just recently I swear
there's a silver lining with all those
kovat and business is shutting down
there is still in Texas a Jazzercise
studio you Jazzercise and I know that
many of you are asking with the
Sampson's sketch is any any enhancements
pure crowder and it doesn't happen by
accident cuomo right we have that in
common
Dinesh D'Souza is going to be on the
show today which I very much enjoy him
as a guest my half-asian lawyer bill
Richman is here yo quarterblack gear are
you very disappointed in my chest
inappropriate I wish we didn't do this
live to tape and one of the day is Dow
Reserve cab giant rallying I see what
you did yeah it's a horrible truck this
tough question of the day does it seem
that governor we're gonna be talking
obviously about what's going on in
Minneapolis we don't have all the info
yet but I also want to talk about
Gretchen Whitmer and if you think she's
going to the next AOC also if you
believe that she is actually evil
spoiler alert but first this is
hopefully what happens when Joe Biden
debates Donald Trump or stop work on
roads and bridges so what does the human
cost listen you gotta let stop work on
roads and bridges so what does the human
cost
[Music]
not edited from what I hear in the Daily
Caller say let's go stop work on roads
and bridges so the guy on the other
Solinsky was like it was real but then I
looked at that guy's face in here could
be the leader of the free world
I don't think Joe Biden is going to
debate Donald Trump in person maybe on
skype
yeah cuz you can have a directional
lavalier mic but he can't do a debate
just for the walk we all use yeah yeah
you never know when you're gonna get the
walking part and did ride this show off
with farts yeah just want to make sure
that you talking about Minneapolis and
all this cruelty and all this division
so you know we figured that we would
just sort of pave the way a little bit
throw you off the scent with Joe Biden
funny leading the nuts is a Peruvian
mayor by the way he was caught breaking
curfew to go drinking curfew with the
conferees to avoid arrest he actually
jumped into a coffin he jumped into a
coffin he pretended to be dead from a
coronavirus it didn't work yeah and this
is why I have very little respect for
Peru no eccentric okay so it should be
noted that he did though allegedly find
some inspiration from a retro and
they're doing us a lot with films a
retro actively Co vid sensitive a
friendly re-edit of my girl let us pray
in silence
[Music]
his face hurts and where is this plan
says he can't see without his glasses
put his glasses out by the way the death
certificate reads kovat oh it's just you
would think it was the bee sting right
the bees have the Cova the bees have
like they did they spread it that way
just like that crappy film with Mark
Wahlberg what was it called
I was the bees in the wind Oh happening
turning to science because we are the
party of science that is absolutely true
there's no way may 28th 2020 anyone can
argue for the draconian lockdowns that
we have seen in this country no based on
science or data that's it you guys are
that's it yeah yours is based on emotion
people who say we need to ease into
reopening and do it in a responsible way
that's the party that's the ideology of
science that's it you're done everyone
loves the winner that's us no one likes
the loser that's you turning a science
guide you to find that some women
there's a whining about a my angry yes a
little bit so in science that some women
now they're actually using virtual
reality headsets to make the process of
birthing their baby more bearable
yeah coincidentally Gerald's wife does
the same thing during sex yes Wow
oh wow it's almost like I'm not here oh
no okay man you know guys this is you
know jokes are supposed to be not that
true I was told I was told it would
enhance the experience by the way it is
not I will say this Jerell the only
reason we rag on Jones because he can
take it he actually is very smart it's
got a nice big penis a nice listen it's
not big news I was editorializing a
little bit hey whose name is that that
would be you nice that's the descriptor
to Gerald's wrote on your penis yeah
what can I say here good good this is
we can label this week news 10
Pinocchio's are gonna be like see
Pinocchio see Gerald not the same size I
think it was labeled fake news when his
way said don't worry happens to lots of
guys so I don't like the direction of my
life right now
finally we do actually we do have some
sad news to UM to get to and this is I
say sad it's really not that sad but
because people write another thing in
sad I don't know what a later
this is he said it's a silly place an
alligator rumored to have belonged to
Adolf Hitler has died this comes from
the associate eyes though the zoo noted
that animals are not involved in Warren
politics and it is absurd to blame them
for human sins tell that to Adolf Gator
you know why the dimensions are perfect
for the armband and this is to think
your label don't realize this though a
lot of the Nazis pets they just refer
and there's a lineage of them you know
some of them went to Argentina right
that's weird yeah I don't know where
else it started but it's been a lot it's
been an ongoing probably no idea and I
want to be clear what we're about to
talk I don't want to condone it or some
fortunately I think I think the Nazi
pets the end they need to be eradicated
they eradicated though you are the ones
to whom we're gonna issue final because
they're ant they're anti-semitic there
has been a pandemic of anti-semitic Nazi
pets that have gone out and created a
whole new genetic lineage and it's a
problem which brings us to this week 7 +
1 I always forget that's what gets you
as the one who cheers this week is seven
seven plus one of history's most
notorious anti-semitic animals yeah
serious business we're steering right
into the pandemic not a end we are all
condemning these animals with a long
asteroid history of a track record of
being anti-semitic now number seven
Joseph gobbles that one's been a real
problem oh wow Nazi Turkey persuasive
wonder how the jacket stable on number
six that's the fashion question so
inquisitive numbers though this one
actually she didn't some I don't know
that she was anti-semitic so much as she
was an accessory number six of our seven
plus one most anti-semitic animals was
of course Ava brown bear so that was a
big one yeah we'll never know if she was
in that bunker uh bill half-asian bill
Richman give us number five number five
of our seven plus one most anti-semitic
animals the Klu Klux Klan yeah and if
you look they really and they fly in v's
so it creates a headwind to protect the
other hoods from flying off if it was
chickens it would be the clue cluck
cluck cluck yes cluck cluck cluck cluck
it would become president pro tempore
room of the cent
yeah a little bit of a Robert Byrd joke
it's a genre number four and these ones
because now they've actually migrated
from Asia you know you've heard about
this the Japanese killer Hornets yeah
now this is a problem that we have
number four the cyclone bees so that's
uh damn a real deadly Wow yeah and
number three you know I don't want you
guys to have this kind of heat I'll just
read these I don't want to oh well this
one was this was a this was a performing
artist this person went viral after this
animal and a lot of people didn't really
understand what was being subliminally
pushed there so you can read us number
four and number three you mean Oh number
three wasta cats
yeah that was that was bargainer it was
staying on brand very smart this show
very smart yes no that cat is very small
sure she because he could have been more
on the nose but instead he just directed
people to one of the most notorious
anti-semites of her time in Bogner who
also have to be musically very gifted
yeah but disgust yes separate the art
from the art right yeah you attract more
Aryans with honey and vinegar
number one most anti-semitic animals
throughout history and this you know
some of them they traveling we have the
Ku Klux Klan they travel in packs right
and then sometimes you just have you
have your lone wolves which are a lone
wolf I should say plural only
lone wolf it's a problem as well so who
can forget you remember the infamous
storm front ant eater so that's just but
he X oh he acts alone see this that
means now you're welcome
is that a polar bear I have no idea it's
yeah get your you don't know you guys
they eat them before they can grow look
if anyone knows their animals here it's
me all right yes very very and I'm just
proved it and the number one most
anti-semitic animal that we could think
of of course was the Gestapo Potamus
that was yeah what is it wearing that
like spike tails like the wrong war
point you're running out of ideas and
our plus one most anti-semitic animals
of all time is actually congresswoman
Elon Otter by the way I know people are
going to get upset and say well why why
could you make light how could you make
light of the Nazis Plus do you think
that we're making do you understand that
we're making fun of Nazis if you think
the SS would be flattered look at the
jacket powerful animals that's very much
an that no of course
it's not always the work of the udin
okay
Hitler sometimes just the work of
incredibly immature hosts who are tired
about tired of covering covet that's
true
and so we figure we would throw those
salts in in your wounds because we're
not Nazi fans
oh yeah how mad do you think they were
like the remaining Nazis when they saw
the land speed records it's like really
cuz the top 20 fastest people ever
disagree you're not even close
yeah we're not even on the same track
you're still warming up behind the
blocks my point is there's a strong
argument there that Germans are an
inferior race is off the hook I'm not
gonna say that username yeah oh wow
that's our correctly uh Steven Carter's
a piece of [ __ ] Oh from the answer from
last week I don't know if I would call
that correct yeah I feel like we should
be including the question let's move on
here to the black lives matter burning
down all of Minneapolis here for people
who and it's still unfolding as this
goes on today so I want to be very clear
and we're going to get hopefully in the
close to Donald Trump's executive order
with social media fairness which it's
gonna be so fair excuse me the mood oh
no fair I would never call myself to
most people call me fair Trump that's
what they say they call trucktown fair
towers do you know they call my stakes
fair steaks medium fair so this is what
what sort of obviously spurred on the
rioting looting and destroying your own
neighborhood productive is was this and
I want to warn you
it's obviously very disturbing and we're
going to talk about this incident with
the cop first that led to this right
because I think that's important so if
you have children right now this isn't a
trigger warning it's an actual warning
the following clip you don't see anyone
obviously died in this clip but it does
give you an idea as to why people are
man
now let me be really I don't want to do
a Covington kid sing right I never we
don't have all of the facts okay to be
clear now there very well may be a
justifiable reason for the police
officer to have handcuffed him and put
him on the ground first right but that
is irrelevant to what I think is totally
unacceptable in that when the guy passed
out he kept his knee on the guy's neck
that's probably something on which
you're not going to change my mind if a
police officers job is to de-escalate
and keep people safe we don't have all
the information but what we do see
there's no acceptable justification for
keeping your knee on someone's cervical
spine after they're no longer moving and
they are handcuffed that's the most
important part it's like if you watch
the entire video that miss Frazier the
lady who took that video is not being
harassed online right but you know the
video itself goes on for more I think
it's a minute and a half yeah where he
clearly passes out in the first 30
seconds of the video yeah I mean if
anything but look at the copyright like
look at his hand his hand is just like
in his jacket like he's about to sidle
up and ask you for your phone number at
a bar right he's clearly cares are you
going to if you really play your cards
right you might get a kirby there's
there's no reason for I mean especially
when somebody it's like and I know
police officers here all the time oh I
can't breathe I have to use the restroom
the cuffs are too tight like I
understand they hear that stuff all the
time that does not excuse what we just
saw there nope there was no threat to
doesn't excuse a this just like
obviously you cannot you can't tar all
black people by the actions of a
horrible person now granted that's more
than one lone cop you're talking about
hundreds if not thousands and then tens
of thousands of people on black Twitter
which is an interesting subculture right
now that I hate to say unfortunately
breeds more racist when they're
encouraging looting but again we don't
have all the facts it could not be less
relevant as to why people are upset yeah
and I think that the cop is wrong and he
was fired we don't know what the charges
will be it's not like a Darren Wilson
scenario where Mike Brown was reaching
for his gun and was punching him
actively and there was an altercation
it's not even like all what was an opera
that just happened
the guy wasn't under control he pet he
reached for the guy's gun right and then
the guy shot the gun so there's two
people panicking this is something that
I want to make this is why I'm against
female police officers let me explain
here what you are seeing is panic what I
want and what we need with police
officers and some do meet these these
qualifications but not all of them do I
want them to be as powerful as humanly
possible so that we can see some bridled
strengths and a lot of people they
believe these myths these lies like all
Navy SEALs or Army Rangers or cops they
can kill you right away first off we
don't want someone whose only option is
to kill you and most of them can't right
police officers get a seminar once a
year the hodgetwins they'd never fired
their side when they were in the Marines
Jacko will incas talked about this he
wants to train up police officers so
that they can actually control people
and be adept in combat because people
often see strength is bullying no
bridled power is how you avoid panic and
let's remove intent from it people get
killed from panic all the time oh yeah
it happens all the time people can't
control themselves they're not
experienced and so they panic a good
example would be how many people have
been bitten by dogs I'm willing to bet
that it's most likely a small dog I was
bitten on the face by a small dog Betty
if she does that she's on the nightly
news and she's a helicopter flown into
the euthanizing whatever place the
euthanasia volcano no one gives you the
point is big dogs don't tend to write
because Betty understands that she does
have how its bridle strength
she's untrained but a small Yorkshire
what happens they're smaller and they
bite you you obviously you played
football nerdy yeah right so you went
there you had played high school your
whole life you went out of seven when
top schools in the country when you're
on the field did you panic and not know
what to do no no because you were
experienced your first football
competition Anik yeah of course do you
panic every time you go into a courtroom
nope
exactly yeah that's the point but wow
how well how do you expect officers who
aren't regularly engaging in combat and
aren't entirely sure that they can
control the situation how do you spent
them and not panic let's use a very
specific example there let's say
Mohammed Ali right we used Muhammad Ali
Jill Frazier Mike Tyson take your pick
if some guy in the street throws a punch
at them now could they hurt him sure but
they could just as easily avoid the
punch yeah and keep themselves safe well
they're very but the danger is a lack of
options
yeah and that's what I see there is a
cop who's trained poorly a lack of
options and very well could be a dick
but we don't know well yeah I mean
that's the question when you look at him
he doesn't look like he's struggling he
doesn't look like there's in the office
right right the officer you know I'm not
saying that he wasn't confused about
what to do or I mean clearly he was
gonna be either he was intending to
cause this kind of pain and results
right didn't care about whether the
result is happening or like we seen a
lot of times they don't know what to do
he goes from zero to shooting right or
here it's it's not even bothering to
check the person right your knee on to
figure out is it necessary or not
necessary because a whole minute goes by
where the guy's passed out right and yet
the officers not checking I don't
personally think that it's a matter of
whether you have a woman or a man as a
cop because there are weak men who will
panic sure like in this example right
you just got to have proper training
yeah but that being said I mean if you
look at the strongest woman in the
military right now they still have to do
a dead hang instead of pull-ups because
there's a difference in strength that's
how they are allowed to you just make it
equal but this one say most women don't
so you just meet the test equal yes you
can meet the test and the quality part
of that test should be combat yeah but
that should be subduing an unwilling
opponent or you don't get to be a cop
yeah exactly you need to have the
confidence to be able to do this and it
seems like this the cop is probably used
to kneeling on male suspects back on the
other ground it's a great way to pin
them down and to keep them from moving
but the guys already handcuffed yeah
this is what you do when you're trying
to control a suspect you I don't know
that they're in it maybe cops out there
that can crack I don't know that you're
in much danger when somebody is lying
flat on their stomach with handcuffs on
right especially when you're in close
proximity with four other officers
exactly or three other officers whatever
the total is like it just seems like a
just a gross negligence yeah can I just
jump in real quick at the point
I did not realize this because I read
many many articles about it and then
watch some of the videos this morning is
that actually one of the officers that
was there as Asian yeah yeah he's
clearly very like East Asian I know and
yet all the articles say four white cops
were fired yeah for easy to say that but
there's definitely something going on
here where has added accurately it
hasn't been accurately told yet dude you
don't know everything but you're alright
and I was disappointed Asian cop could
have used the DIMM mock just so this of
course leg
- obviously the natural response which
has been taking place
burning down in your own neighborhood
here you go
sang apparently she couldn't loot Bed
Bath & Beyond lamps
I think they hear you now at first they
thought you were an incompetent hooligan
with no respect for individual rights
but did we split some photos will Beirut
and by the way it that was going on for
and it only got worse from there who
have known pairs of justice would be one
Papa Roach worse atrocities oh and by
the way you know I don't understand this
has happened in Ferguson and Baltimore
you know who were you who's hurt the
most black people yes do this and you're
wrong and you're racist and you hate go
burn down a Yacht Club you're crying
exactly you don't destroy your own house
and burn down all Corey exactly they
employ black people justifications I
burn down target cuz I feel like I got a
target on my back my entire life so you
could know the pain that I feel there
was a lady in there oh I'm going to Ohio
House an autozone on its back to zone
yeah mobs I guess don't travel well I
guess that's why they just whether they
form they just destroyed and by the way
does no one else notice and Mona sound
conspiratorial but right before 2016 the
election that's when black lives matter
came up to engender wit Baltimore hey
what are we talking about this a few
weeks ago it kind of doesn't win Yeah
right back we went from impeachment
right Russia collusion to impeachment
and that was failed then we had to keep
Co vid as the biggest pandemic our globe
has ever seen them until now and this
will probably also be included into
election it is remarkable to me that it
always seems to come up coming into what
Shh
how does this help anybody and someone I
want to be clear about cut to the to the
black community
okay and I know I can't talk to the Bach
unity because I'm white but you know
what okay this is just me as an ignorant
white guy there needs to be some
condemnation here
let's compare by the way the reaction
that we've all had here with the police
officer white or not recent that's wrong
yeah they also would encourage you right
now everyone
watching go to the big conservative
websites take your pick good a
conservative reddit go to Breitbart go
to have it not have any go to the right
go to hot air
take your pick and read the write-ups
and see if you find them condemning that
police officer I haven't read one that
has not now go to black Twitter yourself
there are tens of thousands of people
saying this is what you get is actively
calling and when they ask for white
people to condemn shooters who happen to
be white who by the way aren't doing in
the name of whiteness we love no problem
we can name them these people right now
these people I mean the people who are
burning things down and starting the
hashtag all lives matter slash black
Twitter they are hijacking your entire
race of people we need to see
condemnation from leaders in the black
man I've been watching CNN all day and
well of course we want it to be peaceful
but this is why no there is no button
this is Wow
there you go checkmarks calling for this
urging this saying this is a good thing
like it's altruistic or it's righteous
this is not good this doesn't fix
anything it's just ORS their own stuff I
say don't give them federal funding to
fix the city right just receive it let
it be my alternator hold on I mean
people not getting funding because some
people made a problem that's like saying
well if you have a certain number of
murders in your city we're not gonna fix
your highways I mean ultimately why
should other taxpayers pay for their
city to be fixed because it's not the
rest of the people that did it I'm sorry
that city that city let it happen they
let it happen so they shouldn't get fit
well why do you think the city let it
happen what do you think anyway that
happened how did the city of litter
we're about care you're talking to kids
and when it's brain short-circuits move
on that's true I cannot do nails well my
point is that I think that you know
you're the intent of your statement
though I think is very important which
is that we need to what got to be fun
how does that feel can you hear me yeah
I want make sure is my message getting
across I picked up the message I get it
hate to Sheba I get it just make sure
that we're being productive so the point
that you're making is someone who
we gonna punish here right what and we
need to punish the people who are
actually doing wrong in to the extent
that there was folks who were letting
that happen
it's truly so I'll be a lot of people
outside of the community that came in is
that happens all the time during riots
they'll come out well into the place
that right it's right so ultimately the
question is like okay so in the same way
that we think reparations are wrong
because you're punishing people who
didn't actually commit the wrong
I do think punishing the rest of the
city because you know let's say five
thousand people were participating in
that riots right how about this I think
maybe you're you're miss yeah
communicating here no state funding at
all to that city or federal fight if the
city the municipality they wants to
spend they sure if the taxpayer said we
want to fix our city sure but the rest
of people in the station yeah I can I
can see that well I don't even so what
did this happen yesterday or was the day
before that this happened it was
yesterday
okay cryogenically frozen remember I
couldn't remember if it was the day
before sorry I was wheel you out from
next to Walt Disney pretty much is this
so so the cops have been fired so
immediate action was taken and they're
looking at this sometimes for justice to
take place like you have to investigate
you have to charge people you have to go
through a process we haven't even we
haven't even gotten today to yet to be
done right and so I don't think that
protesting like this and rioting and
burning things down is ever a productive
thing to do I don't know supports right
what I'm saying is when when the OJ
verdict came out they were they were
protesting the end result of justice not
happening in there sorry not Oh J but
when Ronnie King Rodney King was beaten
thank you they were protesting that
nothing has happened yet right nothing
like this could be taken care of yes
okay well no there's because someone was
killed and I understand that but if
we're talking about a system that is
stacked against you you do need to let
the system work right and see what
happens I understand that problem they
would say well one life lost is one less
money and we agree but that doesn't mean
that the entire system is racist you
could have one racist cop all right well
it will keep you what will keep
following us not just I just really hope
this doesn't end up into a Baltimore in
Ferguson I really do and you know what
what's really in black twitter blackness
is we've talked to you you've spent some
time there in black twitter here's what
I hate this right now will breed more
racism yes yes it breeds more racism you
are
Pech awaiting you meaning youth not all
black people in case you're gonna try
and hang me on that and I don't really
give a rat's ass at this point you
people who are doing this and alluding
right now and burning down target to a
crisp you are going to create more
racists you are perpetuating a negative
stereotype that the people you hate
might use to commit you to treat you in
a sub humane way to commit Adams of
crime against you do you understand that
black twitter when you go is what you
get you're breeding more racist and you
know what else you're breeding you bring
more division in your own community
because you're burning down your own
[ __ ] so black people who own that
autozone are people who live in your
neighborhood I saw that white lady
stealing lamps good job of the people
she's not racist we'll give her she's
willing to participate those people are
gonna be fed up with you start burning
down their stuff this is what happens
the hate breeds more hate right what
happens is oh my gosh this cop committed
a horrible act as far as we know that's
far then what happens is someone commits
another act of violence against somebody
who had nothing to do with things out
then that person goes what the hell then
they bring out the gun to make sure that
their business their place of work is no
longer attacked and guess what they
shoot someone else then that person's
family and then it ends up being West
Side Story with Natalie Wood on a boat
with Robert Wagner my point is it
doesn't end well we should know better
than this and you can see that's racism
yes it's racist to say hey don't abuse
black people in your police officer
don't kill black and black people don't
burn down your own stuff please black
people in this community who are doing
it and white people don't burn on your
own so you know what the story you know
the story is now falou ting right that's
what you're writing on all of these
things you're just distracted from the
problem that we've all needed to focus
on but are completely forgot about his
name yeah what's his name you can't see
it it's all just riot right right
emotions all right speaking of things I
don't like I wanted to talk about this
governor Gretchen Whitmer might I have
this week my finger from breaking the
toshiba did you Lisa no should have I
was gonna Gateway that's the thing dude
you're getting the paper cut um does del
genre slogan he was great on governor
Gretchen Whitmer because he pebbles to
this I can't stand her I think she's the
next AOC she's just a different coat of
paint little older she is absolutely the
worst governor in the country
very dangerous very wrong and I would
say evil and I mean that because she's
actually stated motivations here I'm not
falsely attributing motivations
she has stays motivations which to me
are so disturbing it's almost like she's
saying she's the female social justice
warrior version of Donald Trump and that
she says the inside parts out loud yeah
let's go through the reasons why
Governor Whitmer's is the worst governor
in the country and I want everyone else
to know because she's obviously
auditioning for VP right now the issue
she's making her decisions based on
science and she made it
let's go through abortion first again to
go through the radical agenda that we
see from Governor Brechin Whitmer in my
home state which I don't even recognize
anymore she actually thinks at abortion
is what makes America great all right
she hasn't had right there that abortion
is what makes America great and if this
were a gaffe that were made by Donald
Trump on the other side of the coin
she said that abortions actually had to
continue under lockdown because they
were she's a life sustaining a woman's
health care her whole future her ability
to decide if and when she starts a
family is is not an election
it is a fundamental to her life it is
life-sustaining there I didn't know that
Axelrod's face could be worse without a
[Laughter]
must-play always have a watermark we
trying to give credit when running
something guys of water oh the whole
screen is a water it just says the Acts
files life-sustaining so keep in mind
this is this is why it matters context
matters kinda like the tweet questions
let's fix that going forward elective
procedures weren't allowed in hospital
yeah right elective procedures well she
wanted abortions to be provided at will
up until birth period pretty much that's
her world view I don't know the exact
regulations in Michigan elective
procedures included things like knee
replacements hip replacement serious
reconstructive surgery on your joints
and ligaments
those were elective but abortion is
life-sustaining which is to be clear she
actually plays this game
as governor when it's called the antonym
game where she says something she looks
the exact opposite de life-sustaining
means murder a baby again it's opposite
a man yeah yeah I was trying to be more
clever by saying antonyms know what that
ship has sailed a long way 7+1
anti-semitic animals again thought you
were really right there that often but I
think she's a fascist [ __ ] and I mean
that not everyone just her but because
before we get to the lockdowns she
outright tried to ban all vaping by the
way in her state until the judge
suspended the order it went to a higher
court and I now I think she wants to
bring it to a super yeah she still wants
tobacco flavored vapes to be available
because people don't like them exactly
is a flavor by the way they're not
extracting it from leaf of tobacco right
they're just putting an old sock juice
so that it tastes disgusting she doesn't
want the gummy flavor to be out there
because she knows people will enjoy it I
was in Michigan and I gas stations have
these empty shelves and what used to be
they said oh those were our VIPs but the
governor says so we can't have it now so
what happened is they people just buy
cigarettes we go backwards in here so
one of the the justices actually wrote
one of the opinions that she just like I
have to write this here's like I have no
idea how that the judge has tried to
link vaping to Co vyd but she did yeah
she did in her report saying you know
she's trying to tie it to Cova 19 in
your preparedness and taking we're
hitting it long before kovin and now
she's trying to tie yes you find it now
wait you're trying to study the mating
patterns yeah of the clue quacks clan
and you got no grant and they go no
we're trying to study the Klu Klux Klan
mating patterns in relation to cope in
the Justice actually wrote you you see
this with her if you give her an inch
she is going to try and take a mile
yeah and try to push her policies no
matter what she has to do to cover it
yeah that was like wow that's really
severe justice that try to say she is
like a 70 something percent approval
rating what almost no governor's have a
seven percent approval rating just the
smokers the vapors alone would bring
your average down and the barbers now
and it is something we're fine
ground like libertarians people who
don't even necessarily use nicotine
products or vapes because you believe
that people should be able to put in
their own body whatever they want and
the left because you guys love your
drugs
shouldn't we all do the fun some kind of
common ground here how a governor
shouldn't be able to ban vaping and by
the way there is a relation to nicotine
in covent they're conducting a clinical
trial because it seems to actually
drastically reduce your chances of
having severe really I can't we're not
supposed to talk about it on on YouTube
but no one happens is it actually down
regulates the I think a Stu receptor so
it happened in China you know happen in
China that's why our deaths are low what
this all the smoking they went to zero
highest percentage of smokers I think
China in the world are one of them I
think it might be Okinawa we could have
to ask our resident Okinawan so they
noticed that's like some thirty forty
percent of Chinese people smoked but it
won't like a very small number of CO vid
patients who smoked and most them are
asymptomatic so then they said let's
find another population that smokes a
whole lot France and when I saw people
who smoke again far lower than the
population and now they're actually
conducting a clinical trial or Clint I
think it's a trial not even a study on
nicotine's effect on kovat affecting
those receptors in your lungs and by the
way they're not saying smoke cigarette
right separate nicotine from cigarettes
right we can do within the line people
tell you that it cures everything from
SARS to AIDS can we admit that people
have smoked for a long time because
there's some kind of a benefit and if we
can remove nicotine from inhaling tar
into your lungs maybe it's something to
study anyway I got off on it you think
it's just a natural social distancing
caused by people smell like nobody wants
to be around you yeah that's true I do
smoke cigar couple years ago your dad
and I were walking up and we saw some
people smoking us you guys are still
smoking really that was done new
governor been vaping so right now it's
back to Chesterfields brah wow I didn't
know Chesterfield let's do a thing a
straddle Reagan he had their ads so
here's another thing while we're talking
about the draconian measures that have
been taken the lockdown orders and
they're worse than you think in Michigan
I even just found this up because of our
brilliant researcher reg the beast I
can't take credit for this she had
obviously to start with the most strict
lockdown orders in the entire nation
banning this
of furniture paint garden plans for you
big box stores will also have to close
areas of the store that are dedicated to
things like carpet or flooring furniture
garden centers plant nurseries or paint
now Jim you know some think that she has
an ax to grind because Rena Center was
after her lucky charms apparently she
only has guess who characters from the
board game shine crazy
no just unsightly it's worse don't worry
you can still buy liquor and weed in
Michigan yes trying to get a fern I know
right what about people even made the
point like what if you grow your own
food right what if your what if you're
somebody who's you know sustains
yourself you can't go buy the stuff that
you need but what if you have a child
and you need to buy a car seat you
couldn't buy the car seat at the time
got some cannabis his way he's not gonna
know that it's a healthy care it's gonna
give me the munchies I don't know the
most negative effect we're concerned
well I'm just if you're actually
administering cannabis to a baby that's
not the person growing their own their
own cannabis in Michigan it's legal and
people on it fine but don't tell people
they can't go to whatever I was about to
say beautiful long ago this is America
right so here's something else that's
important it's not everyone's a
hypocrite but this is a different level
where um she banned obviously traveled
to second residences and to keep in mind
context your people don't understand
Michigan you have people who don't make
a lot of money people who make middle
class upper middle upper middle class
incomes sometimes less because they have
basically shacks cottages that haven't
passed down for generations and their
family and people don't believe it
because it's like the Mediterranean
being on Lake Michigan and summer it's
you know beautiful right but this is a
culture of Michigan a huge portion I
think more than anywhere else in the
country they have second homes and so
she suspended travel for folks to their
second homes right didn't apply to
people who are outside of the state that
was that's loophole
thank you Delta so her
husband no travel to their vacation home
150 miles away to supply and here's she
said to rake leaves and he actually used
his what he said do you know who I am
when he's trying to get his boat taken
off the dock over there and I believe
Elk Rapids hey well we can't take your
vote off the duck because of the
governor's orders there and you know
it's Memorial Day I'm the government I'm
the governor's husband like oh well then
you're a big fat and of course I'm not
taking your boy but I think the guy
actually said something I think I'm
Facebook or something like that he said
actually that puts you to the back of
the she actually did say she said my
husband did go up and after the order
had been lifted but there people were
still strongly discouraged from
traveling
she's my husband did go up just to rake
leaves why it's spring so you weren't
you were going to send your husband by
him himself even though and I can't
confirm this there were multiple cars
that were there at the kind of the house
at the cottage he went up there by
himself
to Rick for an entire weekend to rake
leaves
first off I'm willing to assume that you
have help who rakes your lead second
maybe I would buy the excuse that your
husband just was trying to get away from
you and third there is no third maybe
I'm just trying to get away from you I
just figured as I was talking the little
space is he's really the victim here yes
he had a whole plan he was gonna go up
there he was gonna rake some leaves take
the boat out and drown himself and here
we are yeah I mean the guy's embarrassed
he's also not very resourceful because
if you learn to drown himself just just
walk into the lake and don't stop not
here to get back to the leaves not the
leaves the buds cuz it's spring if I
don't get some Gretchen's gonna beat me
no fun when I'm not going she now my god
first a boat no this
and here's the thing she responded by
the way and this is something to me that
is so disturbing and why I want everyone
please if I've done nothing share this
share this with everyone in Michigan
everyone needs to know how awful this
human being is she responded to the
criticism didn't didn't say that it
wasn't correct by the way yeah by
playing the victim effectively canceling
my own daughter's prom and graduation
ceremony but it gets worse my family has
had men with automatic rifles standing
in view of our front window outside of
her home what do you file file in people
have said and written results to my
state justice junk order my daughters
have seen the whiteness of their mother
hung from a noose and effigy we have
weathered demonstrations that were egged
on that were participated in by some the
consignor is from twilight even my
neighbors have been terrorized as they
tried to enjoy their Memorial Day
weekend up in Antrim County your house
to Tara but I was 200 miles away
oh I wait like he did the hyung you can
when you sign do you have to win to know
[Laughter]
you even you can brought this up she's
the rule that she had so you could drive
from Chicago and go up to your lake
house somewhere right and get around
that the point that I was making earlier
about the gardening stuff too and this
it's all these unintended consequences
she has no idea how these rules are
actually going to affect people but it's
like god this sounds like a good idea
let's do that and then well crap now I
want to go up to my ass when you
couldn't go out on a boat with a motor
and affects people in fishing towns who
are hundreds of miles away from her
where they don't have a single active
gate right and this is exactly why we
push back on stuff like this because
government tends to screw things up when
they do things like this don't interfere
in people's lives as much as possible
that is your job she wants us to believe
that a woman living in it ivory tower as
tall as her sister rake leaves that's
punishment fairly certain he lives in
the tower too I don't think he's very
tall but neither is she either way
someone's wearing stilts that hammocks
not gonna swing itself hit the
Bell or subscribe all notifications by
the way on the YouTube because it
doesn't mean a whole lot and of course
we've seen some algorithmic changes have
fun more on that soon
oops and the podcast is on Spotify the
audio version of course to subscribe at
my club level come on slash mug Club if
you can here's the one that's most
disturbing to me fast fact for you we
all know about the New York nursing
homes right what happened there which
affects the entire country's death toll
about yeah yes ok another disturbing
video if you have children right get
take them out here this is if you don't
remember this cover their eyes meant a
town well just diet don't take him don't
take him out like Whitmer doesn't yeah
[Laughter]
this is the man who was beating an old
person old folks home in Michigan in
case you'd forgot the clip okay all
right that's enough
horrible right and by the way thank God
not all geriatric white people are going
down burning down the local alright yeah
well YMCA absolutely are they just
haven't gotten there yet
voices heard but eventually do you
notice me when we go why was that guy in
there in the first place that was that
that was the question like why was he
there and the guy had mental health
issues well here's why he was there and
I think we're going to see a trend which
I'll get to him he was there because of
Whitmer's orders this was a governor's
or he tested positive for kovat and he
was sent there to quarantine Wow now I
want to be clear she just actually
renewed on May 13th so she renewed her
order by the way since we've seen these
results from New York we don't
catastrophic there they are she renewed
the order on May 15th for but it's worse
than New York
forcing nursing homes to house Co vid
positive patients now here's the thing
in New York we were taking old people
who left the old folks home right to the
hospital were sick and sending them back
in like a buzz saw which is terrible
yeah but in this case you're taking new
people who aren't old who have no
business being in an old folks home to
begin with a nursing home and sending
them in just using the nursing homes as
a quarantine it's worse than New York
and there's no way to actually find the
numbers right now in deaths the nursing
home
I've been trying to find them you
absolutely cannot find them right now
the Holman the infection rates the death
rates and nursing homes think about that
for a second that guy was there only he
was beating the crap at an old guy only
because he tested positive for Dovid Wow
the governor decided that the best idea
was to send young people with
coronavirus into old folks homes how
would you want to set they're cooking
the books right now and that's what we
don't the death rates that is just I
mean that I did not realize that that's
why he was there I thought he worked for
the old folks home or something yeah
yeah no why would you somebody make it
through the screening process yeah what
would you say is your biggest
shortcoming hmm
sometimes I beat the [ __ ] out of old
people welcome aboard
thanks for coming listen that's my truth
[Laughter]
right yeah well the old folks home were
given kind of you know they they were
given five grand every time that they
took somebody in for this right so you
gave them a financial incentive to be
able to do this and also they they
didn't do any inspections they didn't do
inspections at the nursing homes to see
if they were even capable of taking care
of people right I think at the time that
we we had this article there was someone
so we're like 10 or 15% of the nursing
homes had even been visited to see if
they were doing a good job right they
are not geared up for this hospitals so
much bandwidth that you have and because
of the politicization that's taken place
around kovat and corna virus despite the
people trying to say you're the folks
who are anti science no no we all knew
no one had any problem with
acknowledging accepting that we needed
to protect the most vulnerable among us
really old people and people who are
already sick but because you wanted to
control everyone else through fear you
ignored the one place where everyone
would find common ground I bet if you
were to poll Americans and say hey
should we send criminals felons into old
folks homes if they test positive people
said probably not no probably not
that's probably not a good idea and this
it is absolutely remarkable to me and I
think this is something we're gonna find
we do have to go to dinesh d'souza in a
second there's no rhyme or reason right
now a lot of us are trying to figure out
we've said you cannot say that opening
up States has helped with coronavirus
right but you definitively cannot say
that lock downs have helped so you go on
a second florida's doing put in New
York's doing badly and Texas is doing
well huh
see my clock downs have that much in
effect why are certain states doing
better than others and doesn't seem like
urban areas are the only factor here
because Texas has a lot of big cities
here's what I think we're going to find
out now that we see what's happened with
Cuomo and once we get the accurate and
there should be an investigation by the
way into those death rates as these
death numbers in Michigan with old folks
homes I think what you're going to see
is go oh history will look back on this
and go that's because of horrible
actions from individual governors I
think the delineating factor here is
that one state said you have to take
sick patients into the old folks home
another state said you have to take not
even old folks who are sick into the old
folks home and Texas said you know what
wash your hands and be responsible yeah
and Florida went to the market recently
so it's remarkable to me that no one is
talking about this because we should be
trying to find solutions at this point
we should be trying to look at the data
and the people who accused us of being
the party of anti signs why don't you
give us a number so we can make an
educated decision
oh I understand you're too busy helping
your husband rake leaves and breaking
out the paddle demanding that he say
thank you ma'am can I have another she's
AOC with another coat of paint this is
what happens by the way we have a
professional that can become governor
this is the scary part imagine imagine
that person with the authority to be
President
can you think of how scary that well why
don't you why'd you blow up Canada well
you know and I've gotten so much haters
for having done that and who's gonna
care about Saskatchewan someone sent me
a mean letter that my daughter had to
read we don't care how about you address
the point how about you address the
science how about you address the data
how about you look out for the freedoms
and liberties that are that are
constitutionally insured to your
citizens in the state of Michigan I
haven't said it's about many people
didn't say it about Barack Obama didn't
say it about Hillary Clinton I think
Barack Obama was wrong I think Hillary
Clinton's an opportunist I don't think
she actually believes anything I think
Nancy Pelosi is evil true and I think
whitmer is evil yeah I really do I
really do when she's talking about when
you hear her talk about abortion when
you hear her flagrantly disregard
people's rights and brag about it with a
smile with a smile and condemn people
who want to live in a free country and
recognize the America they grew up in
and she condemns them and said well you
know what if you do that there's a
lockdown is only gonna be longer what do
you think you're a mom and if your son
mouths
you're gonna give another whack with the
spoon you don't have the authority to do
that but this is exactly what happens
when you have professional victims the
social justice warrior feminists left
who get any kind of power and what what
are life how would I characterize if I
had to if I had to missus Whitmer if you
can't say it better than Jack Nicholson
then I'm just gonna let him say it I
think of a man and I take away reason
and accountability okay well there you
go and we're gonna be back with the next
we need that TV back and that's just
[Music]
does anyone have anything like M&Ms or
something like that
what do you say you got drug yeah what
are you gonna do give me something just
so I'll show you cuz I have a giant butt
and I have an inverted sternum some
coffee beans okay let's see how many
coffee beans we can fit right one here
we go to everyone count three four this
is a family show busy 6:26
how many can we fit before they start to
trickle no 23 24 25 you're gonna be way
off 39 coffee beans in my sternum that's
missing three 455 she's gonna go on
these coffee beans weren't from black
rifle coffee but wouldn't it be cool if
they were look at displayed my sponsor
with purpose black rifle coffee calm
slash Crowder entering the promo code
Crowder you get 20% off listen this is
my favorite we've talked about the
vintage blend is my favorite I'm a
coffee snob block rival coffee veteran
owned and operated but the fact that
they make better coffee than other
companies out there so if you want to
know that your money is going to a
company who cares and I'm not going to
name names like Starbucks Dunkin but buy
coffee anyway buy better coffee that
also doesn't fly in the face of ever
than you believe black travel coffee
calm slash Crowder and turn from a coke
router 20% off I'm smelling the gas
hello my name's qvg now it's always
smart to use personal hygiene practices
but in this time of strife don't forget
to use your face protection here I have
personally drawn this diagraph ik to
demonstrate here protect yourself
mr. QED where's your mask it's not that
jibba jibba mr. qvg can't get sick
mr. qbg already has sickle cell you
can't get two things at the same time
fool ladder with credit.com /mo Club I
suggested to you your friends and your
family
now I know what you're thinking did he
fire 14 rounds or 15 that's erroneous as
my new Allsteel ppq five-match has a 17
round magazine plus one in the chamber
with the best ergonomics in the business
I'm capable of putting a shot right
between your eyes at 40 yards away so
you have to ask yourself one question
do you feel lucky well do ya punkk Lida
with writer studios protected
exclusively by Walter I don't know when
this you know at one point there was
dancing was you know is all about the
hips the hips yeah now it's all about
the shoulder what about no shoulders
yeah and um should be too white to do
either but I don't but you are
don't hey player pimpin ain't easy mom
um thank you for watching mother by the
way really glad to have our next one who
is very dad like figure truly if your
dad were very much a disturber in the
best of ways absolutely so I've known
him for a long time he's been in the
show quite a bit you guys know him you
love him always a controversial I don't
wanna say always a controversial figure
actually because I used to read his
books when I was younger my family
particular wife's parents made her read
the books like they made her read all
conservative books I look I chose to
read dinesh d'souza only he only
recently become controversial to people
even though he's somewhat professorial
like he's not he's not a van Basten guy
he's a nice guy and perfect diction you
know I'm uh spoiler alert it is at
dinesh d'souza where you can follow me
is a new book coming out available I
believe June 2nd United States of
socialism mr. D'Souza how are you sir
hey great to be on the show I I agree
with you I'm an apostle of moderation
but one who's living in in moderate
times oh there you go you look angry you
were just so happy off air and you
your is that salmon color your at shirt
what is it well you know now that now
that we're all kind of schlepping at
home I think you'll see a little more
casual look than you normally see okay
and well I'll try to be no less
philosophical though and serious yeah
okay I don't know if I would have taken
Aristotle is seriously in a tummy he'll
figure pink polo but it works for you it
works for you first off you have the
book obviously United States of
socialism that'll be available June 2nd
I wanted to talk with you about
something specific Dinesh because
obviously you know you had your house
arrest ankle bracelet situation we're
very glad that you were pardoned but now
with Mike Flynn and everything going on
I think some Americans may be in the
dark a little bit as to how these wings
of whether it's the FBI DOJ can be
politicized and used as a tool you know
political weapon what did you experience
with that and do you think that it plays
into it all you know Mike Flynn knows
it's where you sort of a shot across the
bow being the first major name that I
remember being pardoned by Donald Trump
well I'll just give you an idea of how
it went down in my own case I was
literally in Central Park reading a book
when a friend of mine called and said
that they had been contacted by the FBI
and that the FBI was asking questions
about me in such a manner that they
thought that they might be trying to
come after me or arrest me so I you know
I didn't have a criminal attorney I
called a film attorney I don't imagine
you at a criminal attorney because
attorney because you were reading a book
in Central Park
I appreciate leading a book in Central
Park and the only lawyer I dealt with
was the lawyer who basically does legal
work for our films so I contacted him in
Los Angeles and he goes Dinesh this is
quite serious hold on I'll bring on my
partner who's the former District
Attorney for Los Angeles and so that guy
comes on and he he reads me the ride act
he says basically put down your book go
to your apartment
take all values that you have in your
apartment all your financial papers
anything to do with your work your
computer any books that you that you
think are important and move them into
storage immediately and hide the key
because if you are subject to an FBI
raid they will clean out your apartment
they will put everything in boxes you
might not see it again for months if
you're you have ongoing work it's gonna
be seriously disrupted and so I you know
was sort of taken I had a kind of cold
shock when this occurred yeah and so I
went and did those things and that was
the start of my dealings with the United
States government the case that came to
be known as the United States of America
versus Dinesh D'Souza yes that's a very
it almost seems like a parody title I'm
a man he just won't stop reading his
books Central Park
sometimes Thompson square pipes it never
ends by the way book is euphemism for
crack we need to be very clear with the
audience here just so we I'm not
investigating you know I gotta tell you
that I think that phrase United States
of America versus Dinesh D'Souza is it's
more chilling when you're an immigrant
because you don't feel like you have
roots in this country you don't have
family here so this idea that you have
the full force of the United States
government arrayed against you is kind
of terrifying as it turned out there
were at least a half dozen FDA FBI
agents assigned to my case literally one
guy was going through all my bank
statements another guy was going through
all my tax returns a third guy was
reading all my books right that's the
guy feel really sorry for but the idea
they were trying to see if I had
basically made some Cavalier statements
about campaign finance reform so they
could then say to the judge this guy
violated law cuz he doesn't even have
any respect for the law so you know the
whole idea that you've got this little
army of paid Stooges being directed by
someone and that's really the what
worried me from the beginning who is
giving the order here who's behind this
well that's my question to you based on
you know sort of Flynn and I want to get
your thoughts on quote-unquote Obama
gate and if you think that this could in
any way be related to that or if we're
going to see anything maybe in some sort
of discovery here that they could be
connected because it does seem like
political opposition to Barack Obama
were targeted systematically and and now
seeing what happened with Flynn I think
it's a good time for Americans to pay
attention because it could happen to to
anyone including Democrats oh sure I
mean my cases looking back on it was a
kind of a miniature preview of what was
to come when a much bigger scale and in
fact when I had a meeting last November
my family did with Trump he literally
said he goes to Nash what they did to
you they're trying to do now to me so he
saw it as an enlarged replica of a sort
of deep state political hit so in my
case the front man was this Indian guy I
kind of referred him as on Twitter as
Indian head waiter Preet Bharara the
former head of the Southern District of
New York but where I resist around
Ballmer the angling for Eric Holder's
job and he was taking direction from the
holder Justice Department holder of
course being Obama self-confessed
wingman so you know it's kind of funny
because I speak on campus these days and
people go wilderness you know you keep
saying that Obama was mad because you
made a stupid movie what makes you think
the president the United States even saw
your dumb movie and I'm like well the
reason I think that is that right after
the movie came out it was being vilified
every single day on a website that
happened to be called Barack Obama calm
and that's where I got the weird idea
that maybe when Barack Obama wasn't
entirely happy with the movie dead
giveaway dead giveaway yeah and this is
scary because I think a lot of people
don't necessarily look at this as you
know holistically and that this is sort
of the endgame and byproduct of
socialism and we sort of see it in this
transitions into you know the
coronavirus kovat 19 where it's the same
idea right targeting voices of dissent
in your case finding something that you
can pin on them are with Mike Flynn
getting them to lie putting pressure on
them by threatening their their family
with the same thing now with people
being intimidated into silence with
executive orders intense lockdown
measures I mean whitmer we just talked
about oh my gosh I don't want to talk
about anymore
let me ask you I know you've talked
about I think you've used the term sort
of sneak peek this is a sneak peek at
socialism covet 19 do you think that
there's a motive to intentionally use
this to sort of implement an expanded
government through panic well yes now
remember for Marx he didn't think
socialism needed a panic he didn't think
it needed even tactics March didn't even
try to organize the working class
because he thought that the socialist
revolution would come automatically that
the working class would become so
impoverished and misery to use his term
that it would revolt now that's never
happened for Marxist time to now
anywhere in the world so I kind of did
in that the working the middle working
class in America did revolt and elect
Trump so went the other direction but
yes that's exactly right today a working
class live more likely to be found in a
trump rally so the leftist figure out
that that they can't count on that
proletariat they need new proletariat's
and so I think this is part of the
reason why our socialism today is a
marriage of socialism and identity
politics because there is genuine racial
grievance so you try to get a racial
proletariat and then you try to get the
women you try to get the gays and
transgenders you try to get the illegals
so the Democrats here are trying to
cobble together a kind of multifarious
coalition of presumed victim groups to
produce their Democratic majority that's
why socialism has taken on a kind of new
face in the United States I also think
that's why you can't just refute it by
saying it did work before so it won't
work now right because we're dealing
with in some ways a new type of
socialism yeah I think that's a good
point and I also think it's it's tough
to say well it didn't work then people
go well mark so they go well Lenin and
they point to Denmark who by the way
they tell Bernie Sanders stop saying for
socialist if you are not socialist but
they point to any sort of you know
Scandinavian socialist countries and
we've talked about that quite a but I
think the laziest argument and I
appreciate you pointing it out would
just be to say we'll call them Karl Marx
was crazy sure but there are other
examples of socialism light sometimes
people even point to Canada where I'm
from despite the fact the health care
system is broken so um there are
multiple examples of socialism and
that's what you see people sort of
saying right and then the media here on
the left like well people want to say
it's socialism but roads aren't
socialism fire
fighters aren't socialism so they're
trying to incorporate a little bit of a
new brick how would you define the
current brand of socialism and I know
listen we're staying on social them
because that's it's obviously your book
United States of socialism but how would
you say it differs today versus how
people might define it in their mind
well I think that the left is trying to
point to the successful model of
Scandinavia but their actual model is
far closer to Venezuela to take a single
example Venezuela has identity socials
in the same way that we do they've
outlawed Columbus Day ago Chavez the
former ruler of Venezuela was an
indigenous sky and he demonized the
white people of Venezuela he drove out a
lot of the foreign companies and foreign
businesses because he claimed that they
were they represented white supremacy
now by the way none of this occurs in
Scandinavia you can't go to Scandinavia
where every third guy's named Sven and
go you know that guy's a rich guy we got
to get rid of that Sven no he's men do
he's part of it he's part of the Nordic
population so Scandinavian socialism is
all about we're all in the same boat you
don't have this demonization of the rich
Columbus day is perfectly fine their
only complaint is that Columbus wasn't
named Sven the left doesn't want to go
there the Scandinavians also by the way
they don't kill the goose that laid the
golden eggs they they're pretty
socialist and wealth distribution but
they're not socialist and wealth
creation and the proof of that is that
they have corporate tax rates no higher
than those in America they have no
minimum wage by and large they have no
wealth tax they have no inheritance tax
only one Scandinavian country tried
universal basic income Finland and they
got rid of it right the Scandinavians do
not impose the financial transaction
fees that Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders have talked about imposing on
Wall Street so the truth of it is that
the left and they know this deep down
they don't actually want to use the
Scandinavian model their model is
actually the Caracas model I think it's
a very good point one that we've talked
about in the show quite a bit and
something that really surprised me in
researching the Scandinavian models is
when you take swedes and you take them
out of suite
so Swedish Americans or Danish Americans
they actually have a life quality when
you include you know average income
their quality of life regarding health
and longevity it's 50 something percent
higher another numbers I believe it was
54 percent of a higher quality of life
on the index scale for Swedish Americans
than Swedes in Sweden or Danish
Americans than those in Denmark so that
was surprising to me and also brings in
this important facet of like you said if
people come in with a culture of hard
work with the culture of you know
industriousness and then they apply in
the United States then it's an
exponential you know growth factor ok
listen hey the book is we're gonna go to
a web extended here because he's just a
foul-mouthed sailor dinesh d'souza when
we're not on at YouTube and they're
gonna ban us any second at the next
issues of the book is available right
Dinesh united states of socialism June
2nd where can people find that yeah I
mean an easy way if you go to my website
just Dinesh D'Souza calm it links to all
kinds of sites where you can get it from
Walmart to Amazon to Barnes & Noble
where you can just get it the normal way
through however you buy books it'll be
out everywhere next week and if you go
look for it on my website it will
reroute you to a scathing critique of
Dinesh at Barack Obama calm we'll be
right back with the web extended for
mutt club members
dreams are
okay so you are 28 with Rico dependence
I see your cholesterol is good you
exercise regularly not a smoker
are there any pre-existing conditions we
should be made aware of no not anything
that comes to mind
[Music]
Mudd Club where you won't be denied for
a pre-existing condition la démocratie
shop comm supports babies we don't kill
them so purchase your baby onesie it
louder with Photoshop calm today
[Music]
[Music]
it's this is it's not even my pipe
it's a pipe and we can see they're still
tobacco in that pipe oh that's not my
bike months old I was trying to do like
the snorkel thing with the journey dance
at that like Arnold it was commando with
a with a reed or what is that a reed
we're doing a hollow grass I don't think
we do the journey is anymore I don't
think I'm today honestly I'm not only I
think and you guys have let me know the
thing with the drowning and dinesh
d'souza there's like a 20 minute web
extended of course for people who aren't
subscribed a mug Club it's thing what
the journey man said it feels like it's
it's past its prime it's a liability
physically because often someone gets
hurt yeah and I don't think I'm ever
gonna top the Greg Louganis hitting the
back of my that was head on the diving
board and swimming with AIDS and I've
always felt like I'm trying to hit the
high-water mark again turning it but
it's never there yeah it's tough just
out of grasp all right guys I had
another close plan for you today but and
that like I said some of this is
pre-taped because I do have a missus in
the emergency room and hopefully
hopefully fine we don't know yet so some
of the elements today are more pre-taped
than usual because I am a husband but
this is the the current draft of the
executive order that we have from Donald
Trump on social media right now and it's
it could change though I should say that
this isn't necessarily the one that's
available publicly right now in the
afternoon right before the press
conference where I'm taking this close
we also have some information that a
little bit behind the scenes so I trust
it and I want to be clear about this
Monday morning so a good morning mug
clip we are going to do an entire
episode with my half-asian lawyer bill
Richman it'll be a barely legal with
Bill Richmond where we will be going
through the ins and outs of this because
he's a he's a lawyer yes and I know I'm
not a lawyer that being said and I
really I like him I respect him I know
Ben Shapiro has tweeted about this I
think he's wrong and I explain to you
why so for people who don't know about
and I want to be really you know I'm not
one for even though we do a comedy show
on his entertainment I don't really
think I'm necessarily one for hyperbole
our country's gone Barack Obama no but I
do think that today in 2020 when you
look at all of the issues that we run
into whether it's kovat whether it's the
impeachment whether it's Russia whether
it's we just talked about today Twitter
and the mob or how they present a OC it
really does come down to the ability of
the American public to procure
information and I think we're all really
excited when new media it's not really
that new right now when new media came
out and I know Joe Rogan talked about
this and we've talked about this where
the gatekeepers were gone but now there
are new gatekeepers and more gatekeepers
than ever because the gate the
gatekeepers aren't just people at a
network but the gatekeepers now can be
the Town Square the gatekeepers have
moved to the sidewalk where they're
telling you what you can and can't say
because a lot of these companies
Facebook Twitter YouTube they benefit
from the safe harbor protection
basically treated as a public utility
it's a little more complicated than that
it's like the difference between a
website or a magazine or New York Times
versus AT&T or Verizon they can't edit
what you say on their phone lines right
because they're a public utility versus
they publish our New York Times can tell
well you can't write for our paper so I
want to be really clear about that but
all the problems that we've talked about
they come back to this they come back to
the public being able to get accurate
information and there be there being an
even playing field for people regardless
of political persuasion and I think
we're at a point now where you have not
only three companies or four companies
but one company alphabet Google YouTube
is more powerful as it relates to
information than any national government
or world governing body you add up
alphabet Google YouTube Facebook Twitter
far more than any government agency you
can ever imagine and this isn't the same
kind of argument that liberals have have
tried to make about guns and
conservatives have said well the First
Amendment doesn't just apply the
printing press that applies your iPhone
because again these are companies that
are benefiting from protections of being
politically neutral as though they are a
digital town square and there's been one
foot in and one foot out and we need
to settle the guidelines and that's what
we've been talking about in this show
for a very long time are you a publisher
are you a platform pick one we'll be
talking next week we have some some new
info coming from some of these social
media companies that have been affecting
what we do here so please do subscribe
join Mudd Club that's what allows us to
continue if you don't want to obviously
you don't have to but we don't make any
money off of youtube a and we're not
able to reach some of you now in new
ways that we didn't know about before
but let me tell you this I think this is
pretty good I think this is pretty good
from the president I was worried that it
could be some kind of an executive order
that you know would say something along
the lines if you're gonna let be tweet
cuz I do fact check be just about did it
but instead I love how you mute your
mics and the clothes and you go into the
darkness instead it's something that
actually is trying to create a fair and
even playing field and if read the way
that it is written right now and I'm
gonna read some highlights for you what
apply to both the right in the left
which is what we've always wanted by the
way I don't want a leg up I just want to
make sure that our videos that our
tweets are being shown alongside anybody
else regardless of our politics and I
want the same thing for leftists that's
why we did our video on Tulsi Gabbard
and search results so hopefully we've
been consistent so let me read some of
this from you this is a the executive
order right
zeki divorcee da 230 is kind of a
working title again at this point it's
possible that it changes so let me read
some highlights that I see here well I
guess I should read the first line which
is by the authority by the authority
vested in me as and I'm not gonna do
this the whole time because I'm gonna
lose its impact I gotta said enough
okay listen excuse me excuse me excuse
me
that's it state by Lee was dead to begin
with very dead who's just she was sure
Dennis what they told me he was
unbelievably dead by the by the
authority vested in me as president by
the Constitution of the laws of the
United States of America including the
federal property and Administrative
Services Act of 1949 as amended 40 USC
101 and 1
that's a letter numbers folks it is
hereby ordered as follows and there's a
lot of information here regarding free
speech being the bedrock of American
democracy I encourage you to read all of
this this by the way more than the green
New Deal one topic at least more than
five yeah so it's not a new Al Pacino
movie and social justice for all
this is actually just about one topic
social media and it's more than the
green reveal new watts new edge show but
duet so here's what here's what stuck
out at me and again Monday morning 9:00
a.m. or 10:00 a.m. Eastern we'll be
doing an entire episode
good morning Mudd Club barely legal with
Bill Richmond it's great lawyer online
platforms however are engaging in
selective censorship that is hurting our
national discourse tens of thousands of
Americans have reported among other
troubling behaviors online platforms
flagging content as inappropriate even
though it does not violate any state in
terms of service we know exactly what
the rules were changed because of us on
YouTube it was declared and that not so
concerning right because we've
experienced this personally YouTube came
out and said we did not violate any
rules yeah the media interpreted that as
though we had and some so then YouTube
felt like had their balls in a vise and
they had to change and create new rules
that we may violate and that's what
happened with the box at pocalypse this
is a weird when people look back through
history Vox at pocalypse people maybe
forget it was entirely because of me
dressed as a woman in some videos and
making fun of a guy who called himself a
let's be queen yeah using no words
that's the reason for these changes I
just wanted to tell jokes um even though
it does not violate any CD Terms of
Service making unannounced and
unexplained changes to policies that
have the effect of disfavoring certain
viewpoints and deleting content and
entire accounts with no warning no
rationale and no recourse so this is
again this sort of would talk to the
motive of stopping political bias later
on down here says several online
platforms are profiting from and
promoting the aggression and
disinformation spread by foreign
governments like China Google for
example which is how you know he was
very involved in this you have a several
iodide platforms and what I don't know
who do you think I'm not gonna say who
it is
do you think who do you think it is
China Google then it goes right into
Google for example created a search
engine for the Chinese Communist Party
just talked about that yesterday it's
like someone's listening which
blacklisted searches for human rights
hid data unfavorable to the Chinese
Communist Party and tracked users
determined appropriate for surveillance
again this is we're talking about the
rationale behind this bill stopping a
foreign agent from promoting propaganda
and American companies that are more
powerful than the American government
mind you being complicit in that that's
necessary in my opinion legally if we're
gonna talk about Russia you've got to be
just as concerned about algorithms on
YouTube Auto deleting comments that
aren't right these aren't comments that
called someone has written these are
copy it wasn't like Oh some guy anti or
whatever which some to turn on your race
racist term here these were comments
that were specifically targeting the
Communist Party of China then were
automatically deleted let's be really
clear it's not about race it's not about
offense it's about the most powerful
entities in the history of mankind being
complicit with one of the most evil
governments throughout the history of
mankind it's necessary order let me see
when we go through this sorry a little
intense with my wife in the emergency
room section two here's prominent among
those rules is the immunity from
liability created by section 230 C of
the Communications Decency Act section
230 47 USC 230 it is a policy of the
United States that the scope of immunity
should be clarified now what does that
mean we're talking about safe harbor and
that goes back to publisher platform and
what we've talked about when we've had
people on this show we've had lawyers
we've had guests I said all I want them
to do is pick a lane are you a publisher
or are you a platform if you say you're
a publisher you have the right to edit
whatever you want if you say you're a
platform and your currency by the way as
a platform is your user base and it's
predicated on the idea of a massive user
base of billions of people and the only
reason they're there is because they
feel that it's free and open
communication then you're not the New
York Times then you're not the
Washington Post then you're not
with credit calm you can't make those
decisions for individuals there's a lot
a little wordy reads like a from
Prescott okay here's a big one by that
but subsection 230 C number two
qualifies that principle when the
provider edits the content provided by
others subparagraph C two specifically
addresses protections from civil
liability and clarifies that a provider
is protected from liability when an
action quote good faith to restrict
access to content that are considered to
be obscene lewd lascivious filthy
outrageous no a little
excessively violent harassing or
otherwise objectionable the provision
does not extend to deceptive or
pretextual actions restricting online
content or actions inconsistent with an
online platforms Terms of Service when
an interactive commuter service provider
removes or restricts access to content
and its actions do not meet the criteria
of that paragraph it is engaged in
editorial conduct by making itself an
editor of content outside of the
protections of this subparagraph we're
talking about again safe harbor we want
to be clear such a provider for fits any
protected protection from being deemed a
publisher or speaker which properly
applies only to provider that merely
provides a platform for content supplied
by others it is the policy of the United
States that all departments and agencies
agencies should apply section 230 C
according to the interpretation set out
in this section that's important that's
about as important as it gets
YouTube for how many years what content
did you create Twitter Facebook and
they've got a couple series now YouTube
like scare PewDiePie which he had to get
rid of because he had an offensive [ __ ]
stream which we'll get into in a second
if any one happen on the platform you
didn't build your sites up by creating
content you're not like even a Netflix
you're not like NBC ABC or CBS you're
not you were like the church bulletin
who people had to people paid a little
Commission to be on that bulletin
effectively at that point or to withdraw
from the bolt and you ran some ads in
the bulletin you ran some guy selling
guitar lessons a little phone number
that you pull off on the bulletin that's
important because now you have to decide
do you want your entire business model
YouTube to be your original series good
luck
or do you want to continue benefiting
from the protections that not everyone a
lot of you have exploited okay
and again that's really it's clarifying
that taking down in good faith and how
it's an inconsistent application of the
Terms of Service National
Telecommunications and Information
Administration NTIA shall file a
petition for rulemaking with the Federal
Communication Commission communications
but Commission that's I didn't use the
plural I was getting into character too
much with looting the target
Communication Commission what I like s
it's just it's a burden gotta add s's
and I gotta add IEDs to what what am i
retired
so file a petition for rulemaking within
the Federal Communications Commission
requesting that the FCC expeditious
expeditiously can we get a half Asian
bills done proposed regulations to
clarify the conditions under which an
action restricting access to or
availability of material is not taken in
good faith deceptive pretextual
inconsistent with the providers in terms
of service the result of inadequate
notice that's important that addresses
shadow banning yeah in other words let's
say there's a hypothetical scenario
where someone puts out a highlight reel
of everything offensive that maybe you
said whichever I'm so glad that they
used up all their powder should have
kept some dry to try and get rid of you
and it's not a violation but then
without properly notifying you there are
changes made to your channel
algorithmically or for some reason maybe
let's say Twitter isn't showing your
tweets to people in the timeline who've
chosen to follow you despite the fact
that that always used to be the case and
they haven't sent you proper
notification in other words if anyone
out there is being treated differently
on any of these platforms and it can be
verified and you've not been notified
again that's a problem I think this is
necessary
as well to any proposal okay this is
another one the head of each executive
department an agency shall review its
agents
federal spending and advertising and
marketing paid to online platforms oh
that's a good one why does that sting so
much because well we're talking about
Russia Russia Russia Russia gate how
many good impressive in running ads on
Facebook how many politicians how many
people who work in federal in the
federal government or the national
government on any level how many people
are using their game paid for through
your taxpayer dollars or a PAC which
often happens right how many ads have
you seen for Bernie Sanders on Facebook
how many ads have you seen for I don't
know Gretchen Whitman Barack Obama in
other words if these platforms want to
pick and choose losers politically guess
what no one involved what the United
States federal government can be
advertising because we can't be giving
you money that's not allowed
that goes back to propagandist Chinese
Communist Party so is Russia the biggest
concern okay let's make sure there's no
Russia and no Biden ads don't play by
those rules I think it's necessary I
would we have this page is empty mostly
boring section five state review of
unfair deceptive practices the Attorney
General shall establish a working group
regarding the potential enforcement of
state statutes that prohibit online
platforms from engaging in unfair and
deceptive acts and practices I feel like
I wants pretty self-explanatory then
this one right here says monitoring
they're talking about some issues of
item line items monitoring or creating
watch lists this is something stuck out
to me of users based on their
interactions with contents or users and
monitoring based on their activity off
of the platform now I'm not entirely
sure but I feel like this is in here
because everything is in here very
purposefully which I'm actually really
happy with because sometimes but
sometimes Donald Trump I was in Barack
Obama he shoots from the hip Donald
Trump and obviously this is someone's
been drafted up not just by Donald Trump
but this seems pretty methodical this
seems pretty thought out and that was
concerned because we just saw the tweet
yesterday I believe people thought this
was being drafted up out of nowhere this
is almost a timeline of all the
grievances that we've seen with social
media saying alright that's not going to
happen anymore this isn't just coming
out of thin air so in this case good
example would be Alex Jones Alex Jones
was banned for off platform statements
whether you like them or not whether you
think they're a horrible or not he was
banned from platforms for things that he
said that weren't on that platform in
other words this is included there began
it's not just Alex Jones it has happened
with many people because we've seen this
happen and that's a violation if it's a
public utility
if this platform benefits from a safe
harbor act that's a violation of the
protections from which they benefit when
they do with Alex Jones one they've done
it with us that to me is important and
it's powerful and I want to see there's
anything else no there's nothing else in
here so I will say this let me just not
to take any shots at him I love Ben
Shapiro I think he's right on a lot and
I think he's right in spirit to be
apprehensive of this because we've
talked about how I don't want the
government to be in charge of what sites
can and can't say because that can
change then it can become the next break
could become president Whitmer and she
can decide what can and can't be said
but I do think it's within the role of
government to ensure that people are
being honest that they are not engaging
in deceptive business practices and that
they are not benefiting from legal
protections that they have no right from
which to benefit so Ben Shapiro let me
tell you where I think that he it's a
disagreement and I think that he's wrong
but I understand the concern and I
appreciate it he said he tweeted out
that here's the inevitable effect of
destroying 230 of the CDA all comment
sections will be taken down no website
has the resources to actively edit all
comments in order to shield themselves
shield themselves from liability and no
website is willing to leave comments
entirely standards free then he tweeted
the invitation to redefine unfair
business practices to includes comment
policing based lawsuits will likely not
end well for conservatives I see the
appeal but I'm wondering just why
conservatives are suddenly so
unconcerned about political bias among
regulators because this isn't putting
the power in the hands of regulators
this is this is what's concerning well
not this is what's concerning this is
where I think that Ben Shapiro
respectfully and I know I'm not a lawyer
and I'll be told that and I want
everyone to be respectful and it's that
Ben is just saying this a lot of
conservatives are saying this and I
understand the argument because I once
felt that way we're not giving undue
power into the hands of regulators the
power is already there the power is
already there with regulators
with our government to recognize
entities as public utilities or
platforms right we already do that
certain entities benefit from safe
harbor laws and protections right that
already exists so this isn't giving new
sweeping power to the government it's
now making these companies who are more
powerful than the government pick a lane
that's what I see happening if this
we're saying and Donald Trump can pick
who stays or goes on Twitter or some
board that Donald Trump appoints I have
a problem that's not what we're seeing
here and even more what I actually find
really inspiring here's this this reads
the same for conservatives that does for
liberals anyone out there who supports
freedom of speech anyone out there who
doesn't think that people should be
shadow banned who doesn't think that
offensive speech should be removed just
because someone in Silicon Valley beat
Jack Dorsey or Mark Zuckerberg or Susan
Wojcicki deeming a defense this is a
good thing for you I'm more concerned
about them having unfettered power which
is what they have right now and the
government has this current power it's
about exercising it correctly and
defining the parameters that have kind
of been skirted and how can you argue
that they shouldn't when especially
recently let's get rid of ourselves in
the Vox ad pocalypse and conservatives
they'll automatically edited comments
critical of the Communist Chinese party
and here's something else where I think
it's wrong this is not going to be
affecting conservative websites for the
same reason that it won't be affecting
the New York Times or The Washington
Post and it shouldn't by the way I want
conservatives to be very clear on this
because YouTube Facebook Twitter I was
reading the tweets again hear them
Policing comments themselves is very
different than say the New York Times or
The Washington Post or let me use a
closer analogy Facebook Twitter or
YouTube deleting comments that they deem
offensive is very different than a user
on that platform deleting comments on
their own channel in other words Karen
can delete your Cova data that she
doesn't like on her Facebook post
because that's her Facebook page that's
why she has a delete button Facebook
doesn't if they're a public forum if
they benefit from safe harbor does not
have the right to preempt Karen as but
she maybe does not have the right to
preempt her decision to remove something
from
no profile Karin can remove it Facebook
can't new york times can pick who
publishes YouTube can washington post
can edit the comment section allows
credit comm can edit the comment section
the blaze can edit the comment section
YouTube provided that it's not violating
actual law that we have active threats
of violence right laws that have already
been outlined in this in this and this
piece of legislation for a while they
don't have the authority to do that and
again this is I want to drive us home
New York Times as a publisher just like
an individual on Facebook Facebook
itself is not and they benefit from the
individual publisher on Facebook the
people who use the platforms are the
publishers the platforms are designed to
court and benefit and monetize
publishers they are not supposed to be
publishers themselves and that is a
really great territory that's been a
huge problem and has made Americans less
informed arguably than ever before
should they choose to be I just think a
platform particular one that benefits
from the safe harbor right they
necessarily they need to be precluded I
will say this this this is the mate and
then I do have to get going and Monday
we're going to do an entire I guess deep
dive as a term now into this into this
executive order YouTube Facebook Twitter
take your pick whoever to Instagram if
there been any of these companies that
are benefiting from safe harbor
protections they need to be precluded
from making editorial decisions you have
to pick what it's that simple I've said
this for a long time you have to pick
one or the other
pick your rules just let us know what
they are and it seems like the president
is hearing us now he's saying you have
to pick one of the other and you know
what President Trump if you are looking
to reach folks who've been championing
this cause for a very long time the
largest show ever in the history of
YouTube as far as a conservative program
would we'd be happy to welcome you and
or not you know what I'll take Donald
Trump jr. as well he's great we love him
we love to having her on the show I bet
you there may be Ella I'll send him a
text with this and
wait I mean tweet I'm excited I'm
excited about this because this also
this puts into legalese what we have
been trying to communicate for a very
long time and a very real fight that
we've had to have here at this show
every I would say quarter we have to
entirely reinvent our business model how
we title how we thumbnail who we talk to
at these platforms to make sure that
we're not running afoul and it just gets
to be exhausting because the rules keep
changing and they're benefiting from
they're benefiting from a statute that
specifically says companies like them
cannot keep changing the rules
this isn't about changing anything this
is about making sure that they don't
this isn't about changing the rules of a
platform and a publisher and about
making sure that people who benefit from
being platforms are paint are playing by
those rules because for a long time they
haven't and I think that's a good thing
okay Monday we are going to see you with
my half agent Larry bill Richman I put
him in judges robe
[Music]
in my life I ran away
and I am NOT going back and I am NOT
going back
[Music]
I ran way up front and I am not calling
battle and I am NOT going right
it's my
Dawkins
Dawkins
you